god of war 3 kind picks up where God of
War two left off we're concluding a
trilogy storyline of the god of war
story the main character being Kratos
and his goal at this point is to seek
revenge on Zeus and all of the gods of
Olympus so his goal is to basically
destroy Olympus at the end of God of War
two he brought back the Titans which
from Greek mythology are the you know
were the original gods before the gods
came around they fought and lost so
Kratos brought them back from right
before they lost the original battle
brought them back to this his time and
is assisting them and attacking Olympus
again we're finishing off a really
in-depth a really great story we've got
the power of the ps3 behind us we've got
the team who brought you god of war one
and God of War two working on tying up
all the loose ends make making this go
out with a bang making this the best god
of war game ever the God of War engines
have been very much an evolutionary
process god of war choose engine used a
lot of the god of war one technology we
just enhanced it made about a massage it
fine to to god of war three it's no
different we're using the god of war two
engine as a base and we're building on
top of it getting it off and ready for
playstation 3 2 weeks ago is better back
we tore out a complete engine lighting
system and enhanced it redid it so we
could get the kind of look that you see
in on the screen behind me there are
rats that are running around on the
float in the floor on the ground we
didn't plan to do that as a matter of
fact I knew nothing about it probably a
week and a half ago and what happened
was somewhere artist got together and
thought it'd be really cool to add some
routes so they spent the extra time at
night putting them together and all of a
sudden they just show
and I'm like guys don't put the rats in
we got to focus on getting some of the
other demo stuff taken care I've no like
okay okay okay and then the next day
somebody took the next step and they're
now moving around I'm like who is
putting this stuff in the game god war
three is very accessible combat system
is very accessible you can play god of
war three is a button masher if you want
we also added a whole bunch of layers
and depths into our combat system so
that if you want if you want the nuance
if you want the added flourish you can
go in and you can huge huge long combos
you just YouTube some God of War combos
you'll see some crazy stuff all that's
done with a very simple very accessible
combat system that you know my mom could
pick up and just you know do this too
and get through so we're treats a
balance and I think we strut I think
we've struck the balance very well on
the god of war products and we have
aren't going to be changing it very much
for God of War 3 our goal is just to
keep piling on the nuance onto the back
end of the combat system but the front
end of it is going to stay very very
much the same and very accessible
you